parce que laurence ferrari qui était sur
rtl ce week-end en on refait on refait
la clericus cup que j'aime beaucoup et
elle a évidemment à la parler de cuba
des des plus grands bonds de vous elle a
dit beaucoup de bien que vous mais saint
jean et faya partie du sujet des trois
personnalités t d qui m'ont frappé et
marqué dans ma vie le premier c'était
christophe dechavanne à l'époque de
coucou et après je travaille et se remet
ça coûte jean luc delarue qui a produit
vis ma vie une émission que j'adorais et
que j'ai faits présentés vous avais
présenté officiellement et cyril hanouna
pour moi c'est les trois plus gros
talents télé que j'aie jamais rencontré
louis ii bat ontanon cette loi de jante
notre pied au dessus du lot voilà il ya
un espèce de dans certaines monde ce
sont des gens qui savent prendre un
public l'emmener mettre de l'ambiance
island et même sur votre plateau on
entendra sa [ __ ] alors vous dites que
votre arrivée sur ces 8 c'est lui qui
vous a encouragé à aller vers plus de
show comme ça oui parce que voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui avait l'habitude de du
divertissement et il m'a encouragé parce
que je sortais du 20 heures donc on est
corseté au 20h on en a parlé tout à
l'heure
donc c'était difficile de faire la
mutation en fait entre la journaliste
perd sérieuse du 20h et au grand huit
les blagounette avec compression donc
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai à me suis
amusé à chanter à danser bon et je m'en
excuse encore mais voilà il ya un moment
encore une fois journaliste se fait de
mille façons hop et deux journalistes en
parlant de politique comme de mode
et donc voilà il n'ya pas deux il faut
être un peu de décontracter n'y a pas
d'interdît le journaliste poète un peu
partout quand ça tient mon vénérable âge
et au regard de l'expérience je trouve
le carré
[Applaudissements]
c'est une belle personne que j'ai
rencontrée dans ce métier vraiment je
l'aimais énormément laurence et j'espère
qu'elle restera longtemps dans ce groupe
puisque c'est une des meilleures et
c'est vraiment une personne incroyable
que j'aime beaucoup